la siguiente función es continua
diferenciable en x igual a 1 y tenemos
aquí la función g definida por partes y
luego varias opciones es continua pero
no diferenciables es diferenciable pero
no continua es ambas continua y
diferenciable o es ninguna ni es
continua ni es diferenciable y como
siempre pone pausa este vídeo e intenta
averiguarlo por tu cuenta primero vamos
a ver si la función g es continua
continua ahora
para que la función g sea continua en x
igual a 1 lo que necesitamos es que g de
1 sea igual al límite cuando x tiende a
1 deje de x entonces empecemos
averiguando cuánto es gd 1 y g de 1
caemos en este caso de 1 es uno menos
uno al cuadrado
o sea que g de uno es cero así es que si
encontramos que el límite cuando x
tiende a 1 deje de x es igual a cero
entonces la función g es continua por lo
que vamos a calcular el límite cuando x
tiende a 1 y vamos a empezar calculando
el límite cuando x tiende a 1 por la
izquierda y por la derecha
empezamos por aquí con el límite cuando
x tiende a 1 por la izquierda y bueno
quedaron bastante bien divididos estos
dos casos porque cuando estemos tomando
el límite por la izquierda
todas las x como van a ser menores que 1
van a pertenecer a este
acaso y cuando estemos tomando el límite
por la derecha
todas las equis que van a ser mayores
que 1 van a pertenecer a este caso así
es que estamos tomando el límite cuando
x tiende a 1 por la izquierda de g de x
ahora justo es el límite por la
izquierda entonces todas las x de este
límite son menores que 1 así es que
pertenecen a este caso y gtx en este
caso es igual a x menos 1 así es que por
acá podemos poner directamente x menos 1
porque conforme la x se acerca al 1 por
la izquierda como se está acercando por
la izquierda los valores de x son
menores que 1 entonces gdx para
estos valores de x es x menos 1 pero
ahora esta expresión de aquí es continua
para todos los números reales y como es
continua aquí en este límite podemos
simplemente sustituir el 1 por la equis
y nos queda uno menos uno igual a cero
que es el valor de g de uno así es que
por el momento vamos muy bien pero nos
falta encontrar el límite cuando x
tiende a 1 por la derecha de g de x
ahora como x tiende a 1 por la derecha
estás x son mayores que 1 por lo tanto
queremos en este caso y aquí gx es igual
a x menos 1 al cuadrado así es que
podemos poner por acá g de x
es x 1 al cuadrado pero ahora otra vez
esta es una función que está definida en
todos los números reales y es continua
en todos los números reales así es que
es un límite es equivalente a sustituir
el 1 por acá y entonces nos queda uno
menos uno al cuadrado o sea cero y ahora
como tanto el límite por la izquierda
como el límite por la derecha son
iguales a cero entonces el límite cuando
x tiende a 1 deje de x es igual a 0 que
es justo el valor que toma g en 1 por lo
tanto si es una función continua así es
que podemos buscar en estas opciones y
eliminar todas las que dicen que no es
una función continua así es que podemos
tachar esta y también podemos tachar
esta otra y bueno ahora podemos ponernos
a pensar en si g es diferenciable
ahora que necesitamos que sea cierto
para que sea una función diferenciable
bueno pues necesitamos que el siguiente
límite sea un límite definido
necesitamos que el límite cuando x
tiende a 1 deje de x menos g de uno
entre x menos 1 necesitamos que este
límite esté definido y para ver si es un
límite definido tenemos que evaluar al
límite por la izquierda y el límite por
la derecha y ver si son iguales pero
aquí podemos simplificarlo un poco
porque ya sabemos que g de 1 es igual a
0 entonces no nos tenemos que preocupar
por esto así es que vamos a ver si
podemos encontrar el límite cuando x
tiende a uno deje x entre x menos uno
vamos a empezar encontrando el límite
cuando x tiende a 1 por la izquierda
gx / x1 ya que iba head x ahora como nos
estamos aproximando a uno por la
izquierda todos los valores de x son
menores que 1 por lo tanto gx es igual a
x menos 1 entonces podemos sustituir
esto por acá y es lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita poner por aquí x menos 1 ahora x
menos 1 / x menos 1 esto es igual a 1
siempre y cuando x no tome el valor 1
pero aquí en este límite ninguna x es
igual a 1
así es que esto es igual a 1 bueno y
ahora vamos con el límite cuando x
tiende a 1 por la derecha de gx entre x
menos 1 y cuánto es gd x bueno como
estamos aproximando a 1 por la derecha
todas las x que estamos considerando en
este límite son mayores que 1 por lo
tanto estamos en este caso y en este
caso
x es igual a x1 al cuadrado
así es que podemos sustituir por acá g
de x por x menos 1 al cuadrado
ahora como aquí estamos tomando nada más
el límite cuando x tiende a 1 no estamos
evaluando en 1 entonces esto se puede
simplificar y nos queda simplemente x
menos 1 que nos queda simplemente x
menos 1 para todas las x distintas de 1
la expresión que teníamos es igual a x
menos 1 entonces como estamos sacando el
límite tenemos aquí nada más x menos 10
esta función está definida y es continua
en todos los reales así es que podemos
simplemente sustituir el 1 y nos queda
uno menos uno igual a cero y observa el
límite por la izquierda es distinto del
límite por la derecha de este límite que
es la definición de la derivada de g en
uno y eso significa que este límite no
existe y por lo
no es diferenciable en uno porque
observa cuando nos aproximamos por la
izquierda estamos en este caso la
función se ve más o menos así tiene una
pendiente de 1 pero cuando x llega a 1
la función g está definida de esta forma
y su gráfica se ve más o menos así pero
cuando x es igual a 1 la pendiente de
este lado es 0 así es que la gráfica es
continua definitivamente es continua
pero la derivada no porque la pendiente
cuando nos acercamos por la izquierda es
1 pero la pendiente cuando nos acercamos
por la derecha es 0 así es que justo en
este punto x igual a 1 la función no es
diferenciable así es que la función g
es una función continua pero no
diferenciables